so we begin with breaking news out of
australia where a court has overturned
the government's decision to cancel
novak djokovic's visa the tennis star is
being released from immigration
detention meaning he can now compete in
the australian open next week his
lawyers argued he should be granted a
vaccine exemption to enter australia
because he had been infected with
coronavirus in the past six months
the decision of the delegate to cancel
the applicant's temporary activity
subclass 408 these are made on 6 january
2022 be quashed
2.
the respondent pay the applicant's cost
bracket including any reserve cost
bracket comma as agreed or assessed
3.
the respondent is to take all necessary
steps to cause colon
uline 3.1
the applicant to be released immediately
and forthwith from immigration detention
well sarah clark is following the case
from brisbane in australia so sarah so
we have a decision tell us about that
and
is this the end of it djokovic can now
play
well it's been a day of delays
adjournments our technical glitches uh
the live network site where we're all
tuning into uh collapsed on a number of
occasions and the adjournments have been
happening every hour we had expected uh
this court hearing to go on potentially
for days but certainly into this evening
but the judge has come back and said he
wants djokovic to be released
immediately from his detention and he
found the decision to cancel his visa
was simply unreasonable and as you
mentioned he's also ordered the
djokovic's costs be paid by the
government i also ordered that his
passport and other personal items be re
returned so i should state that when
they say ordered to be released
immediately that he's got 30 with the
government's got 30 minutes now to
release djokovic from his a detention
hotel in carlton in mel and melbourne so
tran who's the uh the lawyer the legal
counsel representing the government uh
he has noted in the court hearing this
afternoon that they will comply with
these orders but a personal power of
cancellation was still being considered
so tran had requested on a number of
occasions in the hearing uh on monday
that they get more time they also the
government requested more time on the
weekend they wanted this hearing to be
on wednesday simply to gather more
evidence and get more submissions and
delay this hearing simply by the sounds
of it because they didn't have a strong
enough case tennis australia will be
welcoming this decision obviously uh
djokovic is a draw card for this uh they
had tennis australia last week had made
the announcement that medical is an
exemption which was approved by two
independent uh medical panels it had
been approved so on wednesday of course
that's when he arrived and the prime
minister and border force
officers uh intervene and of course
djokovic was detained for a number of
hours at tullamarine airport uh before
his visa was cancelled so this is
certainly a surprise and the judge has
decided uh in jokovic's favor and he has
now allowed for him to be released from
his detention right so what you're
saying is the government council
christopher tran
he um can sanction the immigration
minister alex hawke or the alex what the
immigration minister can now consider
whether to exercise a personal uh power
a personal judgment or cancelling the
visa or is that still possible yeah so
it is so the saga is definitely not over
yet uh the government said it's looking
at the next steps uh chris tran as we
mentioned as a legal counsel for the
federal government he says the
immigration minister now holds the right
or reserves the personal power to remove
djokovic from australia and it's the
immigration minister because the home
affairs minister was privy or part of
monday's federal court hearing in
melbourne so this ruling doesn't
guarantee that djokovic will be able to
compete in the australian opel open
which he's won nine times
the government has warned in court that
it may still cancel djokovic's visa a
second time even after this court
decision so the saga is ongoing but the
government here will be fighting to
uphold its very tough uh border
restrictions which require a double
vaccination for non-citizens so the saga
is ongoing
all right sarah thanks for that uh sarah
clark there in brisbane following that
case of novak djokovic